aucun autre entraîneur de l'impact
n'arrive à montréal avec autant de
notoriété comme joie série henry c'est
le buteur par excellence bien sûr avec
l'équipe de france mais aussi les
prestigieux club d'arsenal et du fc
barcelone suivie d'un remarquable
passage en mls avec les red bulls de new
york
quelques 400 bus est un grand club dans
une grande ville il faut commencer à
agir comme ça on amène des gens de
grande renommée des gens qui ont
travaillé dans des grands clubs à
travers le monde et ont une et on les
amène à montréal mais son palmarès dans
le rôle d'entraîneur chef est plus que
modeste
après avoir fait ses classes comme
adjoint avec l'équipe nationale de
belgique
l'homme de 42 ans a échoué à monaco 4
victoires à 20 matches puis un
congédiement
non pas du tout or on voit que vous
allez avoir la chance d'y poser les
questions lundi à la conférence de
presse on a posé la question il a
répondu on est on a parfaitement compris
la situation puisse nous a pas effrayés
du tout thierry henry qui doit arriver
jeudi soir à montréal a déclaré qu'il
avait toujours eu un oeil sur ce club
il a d'ailleurs lui-même fait les
premières démarches pour joindre des
robes d'impact parce qu'ils voulaient
diriger une équipe en amérique quand les
deux parties veulent faire affaire
ensemble c'est facile la bouche de
thierry henry rappelle celle de didier
drogba très médiatisé mondialement oui
c'est comparable en plus et les joueurs
d'une même génération de profils qu'ils
étaient des buteurs un peu charismatique
c'est sûr que par contre la dynamique
nouvelle que ça arrive c'est qu'en tant
qu'entraîneur chef thierry henry il va
polariser l'attention totalement sur lui
ce qui est normal ça va dégager
peut-être les joueurs d'une certaine
pression à l'aube d'une deuxième saison
de l'impact en mls thierry henry devient
déjà le septième entraîneur du club
il remplace willmer cabreira successeur
de remy garde de lui même congédié l'été
dernier kevin gilmore devenu président
il ya moins d'un an a aussi nommé
récemment un nouveau directeur sportif à
olivier renard beaucoup de changements
afin de trouver la bonne formule
jean françois poirier radio canada
montréal